the deputy prime minister is with us um
dominic rob let's start with that should
we uh mums being told they can't take
their babies into the house of commons
look i've got quite a lot of sympathy
with stella and i've seen a lot of mums
and dads with their very young children
babies
in the house of commons it is of course
for the house comms authorities to work
out what the right balance is um but on
a personal level with young kids i've
got quite a bit of sympathy for stella
but
haven't i seen at least two other babies
in the house of commons so i don't
understand why she's got this letter
saying she can't do it i don't uh would
you look into it well it as i said it's
for the house of commons authorities but
i think there'll be quite a lot of
interest and we want uh you know
effective functioning chambers both in
westminster and the house of commons but
we also need uh to make sure that we're
in the 21st century that uh young
parents were their mums or dads and i've
seen dads as well as mums but it's
normally uh mum carrying young children
around the house of commons i think
we've got to try and make that as
flexible as we can okay mandatory
vaccines um a conversation that needs to
be had according to the world health
organization this morning speaking to us
on the program well maybe in some
countries but i don't think in the uk
given the extraordinary success that
we've had in rolling out the vaccine the
number double jabbed
we've got a big increase have been a big
push to get 12 to 15 year olds uh jabbed
uh the rollout scheme
of
boosters is working very effectively and
as a result we've seen not just on
health terms but also with the ability
to come out of the lockdown the economy
uh bouncing back in a way that some of
the other economies and countries around
the world haven't i know i don't think
we want to crow about that but i think
actually it shows that we've got the
right balance here in the uk and uh and
i think we should stick to our guns so
are we ruling out mandatory vaccines
well we said that we don't think
we need to go to our plan b which itself
doesn't include mandatory vaccines of
course we've looked at the specific
considerations that need to apply in the
nhs and to protect the residents of care
homes but it's never been even on our
plan b to have mandatory vaccines and
and it still isn't should it accomplish
should it be a conversation that needs
to be had though as the world health
organization has said this morning we
debate these things all the time as
we're doing now so i don't there's
anything wrong with the conversation but
most people ask me what's the
government's plan and that's not
what about masks
well plan b says that uh if
we uh right now we're not into plan b
well i think we require a bit of common
sense it depends on the context but for
example in the house of commons when
it's busy i'll wear a mask
and i've seen others doing the same so
again i don't think we need to
divert from the course we're on right
now we do need to be vigilant we know
the cold winter months create more risk
but because of the success of not just
the vaccine roll out but particularly
now the boosters and that's been ramped
up
i think we're far better protected than
we've ever been and in relative terms i
think most countries look with a a
degree of um respective not envy at how
far we've gone um and that's not just
the health factor of course we've been
able to open up from lockdown and we've
now got
growth up economic growth jobs up wages
up so i think we've got the balance
right
yeah but wearing a mask apparently we
all just had it wore a mask when we're
out and about according to the world
health organization it would save 160
000 lives between now and next spring
look we take the scientific advice uh
very seriously and of course we've got
sage and the other uh uh groups the the
the advisors on it on it and of course
there's a place for mars and i've talked
to you about how i think a bit of common
sense comes into this um but but i think
we've got the balance right now but we
will stay vigilant on this yeah but the
boss doesn't does he how many times have
we seen photographs of him of late where
he's not got his mask on last time was
on a train snappers are very good at
catching that well i can tell you as
i've seen him wearing him oh his mask
and then he wouldn't get caught out
would he well look uh i think um i i've
seen him wear a mask and i think he's
very conscientious about the guidelines
okay does he need to be more
conscientious given what we're hearing
about the number of people's lives that
would be saved if we wore masks properly
well look we take the advice i mean look
there will be scientists around the
world we listen to who but fundamentally
we've got a group of scientists who
advise the government uh
they can test the different views very
closely amongst themselves they then
give us a range of options and we follow
that vice and devices at the moment the
balance is right
um he still doesn't worry his mask when
he should do though um 12 to 15 year
olds apparently you wanted the more
vaccinated
by october half term it looks as though
it's going to be at least until the end
of february now before they're all done
well look there's been a massive effort
a massive surge we've seen the number uh
come up dramatically i think it's forty
percent now forgive me uh i think it's
eighty percent uh of uh over twelves who
have now been double jab i think it's
forty percent of twelve to 15 year olds
and we will keep pushing until we've got
all of them uh done uh and and and it
does give us graduation you accept that
so why is that we set very demanding
targets why have you missed it look it's
a challenge but we're ramping up i know
sanjay javid and the team are doing
everything we can um we've seen a big
increase in the number of booster shots
being dispensed we were talking about
that last time we're on the show and
look we set demanding targets we don't
just set boxes to be ticked but you've
set the target and you missed it look we
well we're we're uh we're very close as
you've described yourself in terms of
the time frame of getting those 12 to 15
year olds all vaccinated and we know
that months after years and we know well
we know the protection is working but we
we make no apology for putting demanding
targets uh really pushing the envelope
on this and it's working and that's the
key thing if not on the time scale you
promised but um there we are talk to us
about free lateral flow tests and how
long will they continue
look these are judgment calls that the
health secretary and the government will
make uh the deputy prime minister i i
appreciate that and as you know i've
been very focused on victims law human
rights reform and the whole look the
health sector will make further
announcements on that um in due course
but
we are being told that we should take a
covert test before visiting busy places
so i'm guessing that you're going to
extend these lateral flow tests for
people free ones at home i don't guess
let's let the health secretary and the
the government will set any new
announcements we make on this
look i think it's important to keep
getting tested but of course uh we we
as we found with furler as we found with
other things we need to transition um
from the the emergency stage to the
recovery stage if i can put it that way
not just from the pandemic but for the
economy as a whole and look the health
secretary will set out any further
changes and i know yeah sajid javi looks
like you have these companies very
rigorously i mean
all the time and when the decision is
made i think that they should be free
for when the decision won't be able to
afford them otherwise and they are at
the moment and when a decision is made
on the future how long it will go for um
the the health secretary will set that
out in the property what's going to
happen ahead of um the winter you know
the winter virus concerns there is it
well i think you're right to say um that
during the colder months we need to do
as much as we can not just on the
vaccine and the booster rollout but on
testing and tracing and the other
measures that we've taken it is
important to make sure we see ourselves
through the new year and beyond okay
talk to me about harper's law
we've got the incredibly tragic case of
the the killing of pc andrew harper this
was someone who's responding to a a
burglary
and uh pursuing three suspects he was
dragged along uh car caught in the strap
of the car dragged along until he died
um
horrendous and he was given uh as a
result of a manslaughter conviction he
was given that the the perpetrators
three of them were given between 13 and
16 years i think missy harper and the
police federation made a compelling case
that that wasn't strong enough uh and so
we're going to make it a mandatory life
sentence by the way just to say um it's
not just responding to this case and
i've spoken to lissy uh and the police
fed about it and i and i'm convinced of
it but also the scale of the attacks
that we see on emergency workers uh who
are putting themselves on the line for
us day in day out ten thousand
convictions last year alone for assaults
on emergency workers i think this is
right i think it reflects the severity
of the events and i want our emergency
workers to know that we've got their
back i understand that i understand that
but how does it differ from the
sentencing that's in place at the moment
well in this kind of case the the two
perpetrators uh actually three got
between 13 and 16 years uh there'll be a
mandatory life sentence minimum tariffs
set by uh the the judge that's what you
would uh typically get for um for murder
and i think okay so it's a higher
sentence i think it's right i think it
reflects the severity of the offence i
do think there is something
specifically egregious about attacking
and killing an emergency worker in the
course of their duty and i want the
victims families people like lissy but
also across the country as well as the
emergency workers themselves to know
that we're standing up for them but am i
not right in saying that you can be
sentenced to life for manslaughter at
the moment but as you can see you'd uh
you you they weren't in this case
the option was there sure and look it's
right to question how much judicial
discretion will be left to the court
there will be in truly exceptional cases
the ability uh to adjust the sentence
but but very exceptional and what we're
saying is that the baseline is going to
be a mandatory life sentence um and
those tougher sentences i think are
warranted by the severity of the case
and i think people want to hear us
standing up not just for emergency
workers but they're victims of crime and
i'm going to be done and i'm going to be
introducing
the judge already is what i'm saying and
we want to make sure that the starting
point is a much
higher a significantly higher level than
13 to 16 years but you acknowledge that
he could have given them a life sentence
if he'd wanted to
look
i i respect our judiciary and i don't
think that they did anything incorrect
but it's up to ultimately elected
politicians and the government and me as
justice secretary working with pretty
patel home secretary to decide if that's
not enough and we're saying in this kind
of case it's not enough no but he could
have sentenced them to life if he'd
wanted to look at judicial discretion is
there so what we want to make sure is
not telling judges what to do uh we're
setting a higher framework and a higher
threshold for sentencing yes that's my
job yeah so you're telling them that it
wasn't he did the wrong thing
look i i i
i think
under the rules and the framework which
parliament is responsible for putting in
place and we as government are
accountable for i think the judges were
correct of course we tried to review an
appeal and get the sentence um
raised rob buckland my predecessor did
that that was declined again perfectly
there's no question of impropriety or um
but but ultimately what the judiciary
will quite rightly say is if you want
higher sentences you the government and
parliament must pass it that's what
we're doing okay what's happening about
the uh migration problems and the fact
that you know 25 000 people have managed
to come across so far this year and um
we've seen in the papers this weekend uh
last weekend i should say that that the
home secretary's team are calling her a
[ __ ] my goodness i i look you always
hear
these sort of rumors snippets in the
newspaper i i've worked very closely
with the home secretary i continue to do
so and she's not on laura or she's most
certainly is not and uh but she's very
strong-willed uh and determined which is
what you want in the home secretary and
i know that she's uh she's also very
smart the way she's going about this
she's looking at the operational
cooperation we have with the french uh
the number of how's that going thousands
of uh of votes have been intercepted
prevented from traveling convictions uh
we've got increasing number of
convictions and the fundamental thing
for us is we've got to avoid the what
so-called pull factor the incentives for
people to be taking that perilous
journey and the big thing we're focused
on is cracking down on the predatory
criminal gangs who make their profit out
of this trade in misery and and being
very clear with the legislation the
sovereign uh borders bill that we're
putting through and the other
legislation that actually there is a
distinction between legal routes to come
to this country and illegal routes she's
absolutely right about that okay the
french we promised them 54 million
pounds in order to try to stop people
getting to our borders in the first
place we're not giving them all of that
money and as a result they're buying
quad bikes and things to try and keep
people back i think the french have had
plenty of investment uh to because we
recognize because no no no no but we
our responsibilities this is a shared
responsibility i mean frankly uh
those uh migrants should be assessed in
the first country
that they arrive in and i recognize that
the french have got a problem because
those migrants are coming in by the
south of europe and increasingly from
the east we've seen the issues with
belarus in this regard and they're
making their way to france but
significant numbers want to come to the
uk and what the french will say is
actually in those other countries that's
where they should be assessed we agree
uh with that so actually it's a good
example of where uh and it's election
season in france so let's be mindful of
this the reality of that you're saying
mccron's like electioneering no i'm
saying i recognize that during an
election
this is very sensitive because it's a
reality but what i'm also saying is that
there is a national interest that the
french have and that the uk have in
saying actually these migrants should be
dealt with in the first port of entry
yeah or elsewhere deputy prime minister
it was why have we not given them the
money that we promised them we've we've
given them a significant amount of best
investment i don't agree that we've
reneged on any commitments we've gained
about 12 million quid out of 54. no
we've given them a significant and we're
always willing to work more closely uh
with the french government to tackle
this problem um the reality is we need
to a deal with uh the challenge in
source countries which is why we say
ultimately uh refugees and uh migrants
should be assessed at closer to uh the
region or the country they come from and
ultimately if they're coming in through
europe they ought to be assessed in the
first port of entry and actually that's
something which the uk and the french
ought to make common ground on are we
going to give them any more money or not
look we'll make those announcements in
the usual way we're not just handing
over it's their responsibility to do
this um so it's not just we did promise
we've given money in the past we'll
continue to look at how we can do this
as a shared endeavor i think a
partnership approach is win-win for both
sides um so we'll continue the home
secretary who has a very good
relationship with the interior minister
in france will continue to do that okay
um as it comes up to nine o'clock and my
viewers will want to know whether you
think that the prime minister is losing
the plot
no i think we've got a plan coming out
this pandemic with the boosters
for the vaccine on the economy jobs up
growth up economic growth up wages up
we've put 96 billion pounds announced
this week of investment into uh
transport infrastructure particularly
the midlands
and the north i've been talking about
criminal justice reform harper's law i'm
going to be coming up with a victim's
law for consultation human rights reform
we're getting on with the job and that's
what we're absolutely focused on yeah
but is the pm losing the plot no he i'm
in meetings with him every day
he's
the steward of this government the
leader of this government fired up with
the energy with people talk about the
pent up economic demand
coming out lockdown i would say there's
a huge amount of pent-up political
energy that the prime minister is
driving forward and we're going to spend
the next two three years of this
parliament delivering on the people's
priorities from economic jobs
livelihoods supporting businesses
through to my area which is criminal
justice reform to make sure we stand up
for victims we've got the sentences in
place we build the prisons we need okay
you know why i'm asking you that because
i mean you know he can't even paginate
his own pages then he bangs on about
peppa pig what's a lot about
i think you know one of the things about
the the um i mean i mentioned the
economic reform jobs up growth up wages
up we talk about um great british
exports and frankly in this country we
don't back ourselves enough we're too
much self-flagellating peppa pig many of
your viewers will have uh watched it
either as grandparents or parents i
watched it with my boys when they were
younger but it's actually a huge british
export to the point he was making did
you say that well he did make this point
it's a huge british experience
it's listened to watched in china how
many people will be aware of that and
his point he's making is from our
creative arts through to our
technological ingenuity
and the exports that that brings and the
revenue and the jobs that brings this
country we should back ourselves he's
the one with the ambition the optimism
but also a very clear plan and frankly
he leads all of the other parties and
leaders uh in his wake um you know i'm
going to ask you don't you
i don't i never know
have you been to peppa pig world uh i
have
i
have
with my boys i loved it they're a bit
older now so um tell me about it
uh it's a day of my life i won't get
back
well the prime minister says it's
fantastic oh it's quite fun and when
they're at that age it's quite fun okay
a final thought goes to uh the um the
former health secretary who would be
prime minister jeremy hunt and he said
the government's had a you know pretty
shocking few weeks
oh jeremy's a close friend um i'm not
gonna comment on the commentary of those
on the back benches but um look it
there are all sorts of distractions for
me for the prime minister for everyone
from the chancellor through to the home
secretary
we want to be focused as possible on the
things that your viewers really care
about jobs the nhs backlog crime those
are things we're dealing with
and there's a lot of political
distractions i get that and it's fair to
ask me all of those questions but that's
what we're focused on and you relax at
the weekend by eating vindaloo is that
right
i'm actually you know i made the point
about reform and on the scale of reform
uh as between corn and vindaloo i sort
of pitching it more to the vindaloo at
edge personally i don't ever get more
spicy than a madras or a gel frazee good
to know i'm really honest
it's good to talk to you as always
thanks very much